el primer ministro se enfrenta a otra
acusación por festejar esta vez los
medios británicos informan que el
cumpleaños de boris johnson en junio de
2020 se celebró con una reunión en
downing street para darle una tarta se
cree que asistieron hasta 30 personas
algo que la oficina de johnson desmintió
un grupo del personal que trabaja en el
número 10 se reunió ese día brevemente
en la sala del gabinete después de una
reunión para desear al primer ministro
un feliz cumpleaños él estuvo allí menos
de diez minutos la nueva acusación de
que no se respetaron las restricciones
de kobe 19 llega apenas unos días antes
de la publicación de una investigación
del gabinete de la funcionaria su grey
sobre las fiestas en downing street
durante el confinamiento comentarios por
escrito del antiguo asesor principal de
johnson ahora un crítico acérrimo
dominique kammerichs quien dice que
johnson mintió al parlamento sobre el
tema al principio el primer ministro
británico dijo que no se había
infringido ninguna norma
luego se disculpó por la hipocresía que
supone en tales reuniones la oposición
dice que la última acusación es una
razón más para que johnson renuncia y
esto es una prueba más de que tenemos un
primer ministro que cree que las reglas
que ha hecho no se aplican a él no
podemos permitirnos seguir con este
gobierno caótico y sin timón el primer
ministro es una distracción nacional y
tiene que irse para abrir un voto de
confianza contra johnson 54 de los 359
diputados conservadores del parlamento
deben presentar cartas de desconfianza
si dimite los favoritos para sustituirle
son la ministra de asuntos exteriores el
extras y el ministro de hacienda rey y
una pero ambos han expresado su apoyo al
primer ministro